but he was saying I'm passing four times
on Twitter now he is repeating the
messages you know what he does right I
think that's an interesting strategy I
in 2003 opposite in 2013 I've posted the
same message on Twitter more than once
for the first time in seven years
because I agree with guy the stream is
so busy that if you have something you
want to say you have to be strategic and
I think and listen you give up doing
that no I didn't do it from o-62 mm no I
do it now I do you spam of a stream as
well I don't think it's spam I think
that's your funny way to make a joke I
think what I'm doing is when it's when
it's when it's nine o'clock in the
morning Eastern Time and I want to say
something that's important that day I'm
smart enough to realize that six o'clock
in the morning in San Francisco and I
have a fan base there I need to wait if
I am a loyal follower of yours and I
read the tweets from Gary's IAC four
times the same crap you yes horrible I
understand on the flip side the reality
is the stream has become so busy that
I've looked at my data and my feedback
that people are missing it enough and
not to mention it's so fast everything
is microseconds that you're not so
[ __ ] devastated that you're seeing
something a second time it's not the end
of the world that I saw [ __ ] tweet a
second time not to mention given the
fact that I try very hard to provide
value and respond to everybody at scale
and put out good content I'm putting out
value it's